this is the first of three videos which
are going to be devoted to friedrich
nietzsche's great systemic work the
genealogy of morals it's divided into
three different essays so I'm going to
shoot one video for each one of the
essays and this is one of my favorite
works of Nietzsche in part because it is
like I just said systematic so if you
want to get a good handle on what
Nietzsche is saying as a philosopher
with something like a coherent system
you know he has an anti systematic
philosopher and he attacks many other
people's systems but it does have a
system of his own then the genealogy is
one of the places that you would want to
go to you see a lot of the same themes
that he's approaching in other works
like you know the Antichrist twilight of
the idols Beyond Good and Evil
thus Spoke Zarathustra all tied in
together but in a like I said systematic
way where were the different concepts of
being related to each other and he's
showing how they flow out of each other
or connected with each other the other
systemic work that you know would be of
course the birth of tragedy but that's
an early work so here we're seeing the
mature Nietzsche grappling with one of
the really important concepts the nature
of goodness the nature of value in
Nietzsche and morals and metaphysics and
it's very important like I said to in
the birth of tragedy lectures to
remember that for Nietzsche epistemology
or the theory of knowledge metaphysics
the study of what's most real morals
good and evil good and bad anesthetics
beautiful ugly base Noble all these sort
of things are rolled into one they're
not neatly discernible from each other
and distinguishable from each other the
way that somebody likes a cot would try
to make them or many other modern
philosophers have as well so you notice
that I'm beginning with this this
question here and this is the the what
he's starting from in the first essay or
the FIR
chapter this where did our conception of
goodness of good as a value come from
that's really the central idea
motivating the entire work and it's a
kind of trick question because one of
the things you're going to see in each
of doing in this is saying well there is
more than one conception of good there's
multiple conceptions of good and we want
to trace out how they actually came to
be and how they are in conflict and
which one we actually ought to prefer or
pick or guide ourselves by and also
which one is predominance in our modern
actually for us late modern Western
culture you notice also I have three
different columns here that were
beginning with and the reason I did this
is because Nietzsche begins by
criticizing some other views and putting
forth his own view in contrast to that
so I think this is a very useful place
to start there's also some things that
aren't on the board some other views
that he's not criticizing quite as much
explicitly here because he considers
those of used to be so fundamentally
mistaken and each is actually paying a
compliment to these two different groups
the English psychologists and the
philosophers like Herbert Spencer
Herbert Spencer by the way somebody who
you're probably not going to run across
in too many philosophical contexts
because he was a very important
philosopher in the mid 19th century he
was an English guy who was very
influenced by utilitarianism and also by
evolutionary thought not necessarily
Darwinian thought and such because
remember there are many different
notions of evolution floating around out
there at the time but this whole notion
of development this whole notion of
things taking place historically through
a bunch of little different steps that
would ultimately lead to a larger kind
of jump or result so
Nietzsche starts out by saying that
these English psychologists were onto
something he says these English
psychologists whom one has also to thank
for the only attempts hitherto to arrive
in a history of the origin of morality
they themselves are no easy riddle I
confess that as living riddles they even
possess one essential advantage over the
books they are interesting now that's a
very big compliment for nature and for
him to say that their riddle means that
they also don't fully understand what
their own project is they they think
things are a lot more straightforward
than they actually are and he says one
always discovers them voluntarily or
involuntarily at the same task namely of
dragging the party on 'the use of our
inner world are shameful parts of our
inner world into the foreground and
seeking the truly effective and
directing agent so these are people who
want to know what's really motivating us
what's really making us do the things
that we do all these great beautiful
ideals that we have like nobility and
charity and the Christian Way of life
all these sort of things that people
talk about and give lip service to
what's really going on with that what's
really happening in their psyche what's
really at the root of this so you know
Freud is coming later than Nietzsche but
but Freud would also sort of fit into
that wouldn't he so these English
psychologists are saying things like
well where did this notion of goodness
come from well it came from what was
useful for say the group or other people
and then you would get some sort of you
know good response from them good in the
sense that you liked it you notice we're
already starting to use good in a fairly
equivocal way is that something
Nietzsche is gonna pick up on here
equivocal meaning ambiguous multiple
ways but there are their basic idea is
that you know we start out as pretty
selfish creature is self-centered and we
gradually become civilized by having
other people you know showed his
approval
of our reactions when we're
self-centered and showing approval of
our actions when we benefit them and so
if we make ourselves useful we get seen
as good we see other people who get
rewards for being good and then
eventually down the line we somehow
forget this and we come up with this
notion of goodness by itself and by the
time that we get to the present we're
not really sure what it is but where
things really have their origin was just
in serving the group or serving other
people you know who else would actually
fit the bill for this would be John
Stuart Mill if you read utilitarianism
and you read some of his other works he
lays out a kind of history or a
genealogy historical account of where
something came from like that
so Nietzsche says here's what I like
about these guys they are trying to find
the shameful part of our inner world
bringing to another foreground seek the
truly effective and directing agent that
which has been decisive in its evolution
in just that place where the
intellectual pride of man would least
desire to find it like you know habit or
forgetfulness or a blind and chance
mechanic hooking together of ideas all
these sorts of things what is it that
really what is it really that always
drives these psychologists in just this
direction he asks so he's asking about
their own motivation says is it a secret
malicious vulgar perhaps self-deceiving
instinct for belittling man is that what
these guys are about or possibly a
pessimistic suspicion the mistrustful
'no stuff disappointed idealist grown
spiteful and gloomy and you notice
nietzsche actually thinks this is better
than an idealist way of looking at
things where you know things like true
beauty exists out there by itself and
there's a perhaps a good in itself that
motivates us or anything along those
lines so he says a petty subterranean
hostility and rancor perhaps towards
christianity and Plato that is perhaps
not even cross the threshold of
conscious
or is it maybe Allison lascivious taste
for the grotesque the painfully
paradoxical the questionable and absurd
in existence or finally something in of
each of them a little bulgaria a little
gloominess a little anti christianity a
little itchy a need for space Nietzsche
doesn't actually give us an answer for
any of these he says we don't actually
need to know but you notice that keep
this in mind these people are actually
going to exemplify a kind of rosante mop
carry to the second degree of resentment
against the people who show resent him
up when we get to that concept now he
says I'll respect them for the good
spirits that may rule in these
historians of morality but it is
unhappily certain that the historical
spirit itself is lacking in them that
precisely all the good spirits of
history itself have left him in the
lurch what does he mean by that he goes
on and he says as is the hallowed custom
with philosophers the thinking of all of
them is by nature unhistorical so
they're not there they're coming up with
some sort of historical account meaning
that there's development there's change
over time there's a you know several
different periods in which things are
taking place but is it really based in
history what does it mean for something
to be based in history that's something
else you want to think of that does that
mean that you just go to a book and you
find it there Julius Caesar cross the
Rubicon therefore you know anything
about the Rubicon and Caesar is
automatically historical well history
has to be based on some sort of
foundation some sort of witnessing or at
least some digging into things and
acquiring and understanding how things
developed and and where they they
changed and why they went this way
instead of this way at this juncture you
might say that history is a study of the
processes of human wills in action
through time and so Nietzsche says these
guys are really not historical their
genealogy is bungled from the beginning
and he says you know here's the big
problem
how would this forgeting take place
he says Herbert Spencer actually got
this we've got this you know more
correct he at least understood that if
you're going to say that the reason why
actions became seen as good and certain
character traits became seen as good
certain social arrangements became seen
as good is because they've worked out
better for the community as a whole
that's not the sort of thing that people
actually forget that's the sort of thing
that actually gets reinforced and
brought to light and people say hey do
this because that's good for the rest of
us
so Nietzsche says Spencer at least got
that amount that sort of stuff right
there's another problem with this too
and here we start seeing niches own
ideas coming to life he says it's plain
to me
now we're gonna see Nisha give his own
view first of all that in all this
theory the source of the concept good
has been sought and established in the
wrong place what's the wrong place they
useful useful for another person the
judgment good did not originate with
those to whom goodness has been shown
HSS everything that makes sense if you
think about this this way in which you
know these things would have to take
place in order for me to have a sense of
something is being good I would do
something good to sum something I would
do something to another person which
would benefit them which would make
their situation better which would have
a certain usefulness for them and then
they would approve of it they would
reward me and I would say aha
now I know what's good but why would I
care about approval or a reward wouldn't
I already have to have the notion of
goodness in order to care about their
approval or their reward that's a
problem that they didn't they didn't
deal with Nietzsche is actually not
gonna make that criticism he's gonna say
look that's not even the way it happened
he says it was the good themselves that
is to say the noble powerful high
station and high
who felt and established themselves in
their actions as good that is of the
first rank in contradiction to all the
low-low minded common and plebeian so
good in that valuation is what is noble
and it's the noble people who actually
assert them the saying we are the good
those people over there who are making
our shoes and and bringing in the
harvest and carrying our weapons and you
know putting up with all of our stuff
they are the common they are the band we
established ourselves they have to sort
of suck it up and allow that to be
imposed on them or they can rise up if
they want they can be good if they want
but then they actually have to like you
know take arms and resist and since they
don't they're bad so he says it was out
of this pathos of distance that they
first sees the right to create values
grasping the concept of good and saying
this is good is in niches words a
creation of values a creation of
valuation itself they says what did this
have to do with utility it didn't have
anything to do with utility the
viewpoint of utility is as remote and
inappropriate as it possibly could be in
the face of such a burning eruption of
the highest rank ordering rank defining
value judgments for here feeling has
attained the antithesis of that lower
degree of warmth which with which any
calculating prudence any calculus of
utility presupposes so he's rejecting
this notion of utility as itself being
kind of a low common plebeian way of
looking at things that's kind of
important what that means is these kinds
of understandings are actually going to
be representative of a later kind not an
original kind of valuation and not an
original kind of saying this is good so
how are we going to to determine this
what can be our clues if we're not going
to have some sort of you know imagine
plausible historical account like this
English psychologists do or Herbert
Spencer or a pick whoever else you like
how are we going to get at this how can
we work our way back to this moment well
it's important to remember where
Nietzsche came from originally
academically Nietzsche was what we call
a philologist and to be a philologist at
that time really even today it's still a
kind of discipline where you have to
know a lot of different things not just
the one thing that you're studying a
philologist is officially concerned with
words and their origins and determining
what the meanings of them are and
philologists are usually concerned with
ancient languages languages that are no
longer in process of growth of
fluctuation and which we have literary
monuments for we also have other
monuments as well you know we're finding
more and more and more through
archaeology nature was a classical full
philologist so that meant that he was
studying Greek Latin but you know they
had other things that their resources to
these this is the time when they were
starting to figure out you know that
there was a sort of primitive
indo-european language that you know
Greek Latin Sanskrit you you know
Persian the Celtic languages all these
you know we're tracing their of the
roots back in German this but as well
the Germanic languages Germans actually
call this Indo German because they're
Germans but now we call it indo-european
or proto indo-european yeah and along
with the language goes a way of looking
at the world
a way of life so when language changes
where when language makes distinctions
distinctions are being made within a
world somebody like me she would say and
also people you know later philosophers
who are working off of nature so
Nietzsche says the signpost to the right
Road for me was the question what was
the real etymological significance of
the designations for good coined in the
various languages I found he says they
all went back to the same place this
distinction between good as noble that
is common that everywhere noble
aristocratic in the social sense is the
basic concept from which good is that is
the sense of with aristocratic soul
noble with a soul of a high order where
the privileged soul necessarily
developed so the very notion of having a
beautiful or good or worthwhile or
valuable soul is something that is
developing out of the experience of
nobility of their way of life and it's
counterpose to common plebeian low which
are finally transformed into the concept
banned and he uses some some German
examples he talks about schlecht which
is a word for bad which is identical
with schlicht plainer simple and you
know it gives you so a lot of
derivations of this he says with regard
to a moral genealogy this seems to me to
be a fundamental insight that it has
been arrived at so late as a fault of
the retarding influence exercised by the
Democratic prejudice and the modern
world towards all questions of origin
what is this Democratic prejudice he's
talking about well people are interested
in figuring out what the origins of
things are but basically just so they
can tear down aristocratic idols
aristocratic obstacles to a kind of
democratization of thing
so he says with respect to our problem
if we go back to this it is of no small
small interest to ascertain that through
these words and roots which doesn't make
good they're frequently still shines the
most important nuance by virtue of which
the noble felt themselves to be a man of
a higher rank so what's going on
I'm actually going to do a little bit of
erasing now because we're going to need
this board for making sense out of what
Nietzsche is is actually saying goodness
is not coming on the scene because one
person is useful for another one and
then they look to that person they say
oh you're so good you're so useful we
really love you you're what we want to
be like you're what we're going to
idolize that would be in some sense
reactive instead be good are the noble
and the noble give the valuation of good
to the noble bad to the common or base
and you can see this in Greek you know
Palos ice close you know the noble the
base or tacos is versus the Augusta's
and each other traces us through a
number of other languages and he says
they also do it by a typical character
trait there's there's two kinds of
superiority here for the good of the
Noble there is a superiority in power
but there's also a superiority in soul
so they actually hold power and by means
of this power they impose their will
they impose this valuation
but they also do this by expressing that
they have a different kind of character
than the base
they call themselves and this is a very
important point the truthful he says
this is so this is so above all of the
Greek nobility whose mouthpieces Thea
Janus the root of the word point for
this s Flo's signifies one who is one
who possesses reality in a certain sense
the nobles are saying we possess being
to a higher degree we are more than you
are not just we're greater than you not
just you know we're all human beings but
we happen to have possessed a greater
value they're saying we are something
that has more being than you and your
way of life so I'm going to skip ahead a
little bit he does a lot of etymology
here he says to this rule that a concept
of noting political superiority always
resolves itself into a concept anemic
superior in his soul it is not
necessarily an exception although it
provides occasions for exceptions when
the highest caste is at the same time
the priestly caste and here he's
introducing really important concept and
valuation that he's going to talk more
about in in section 2 which we'll look
at in the next video he says when you
have a priestly caste if that caste is
on top so you might think for instance
about the Brahmin class being above the
cachet TRAI
class in post-conquest India right he
says then another valuation between the
pure in the impure the good or the pure
and the impure or the bad so we have the
the noble and now we're talking about
the noble priests class they impose
another evaluation good as being
pure bad or evil as being the impure
holy and the unholy and he just says
look at first this is not really about
in a holiness in a sort of
transcendental sense this means pure and
impure in he says the pure one is from
the beginning merely a man who washes
himself who forbids himself certain
foods that produce skinny elements who
does not sleep with the dirty women of
the lower strata who has an aversion to
blood no more hardly more on the other
hand to be sure it's clear from the
whole nature of an essentially priestly
aristocracy remember so time.i
aristocracy hear ye antithetical
valuations couldn't precisely this
instance soon become dangerous deepened
sharpened and internalized so already
here what we're going to call it
transvaluation of values is beginning to
take place and it's not taking place by
what nietzsche is going to call the
slave revolt of morality it's taking
place within the noble class itself a
portion of that class is imposing a new
sort of valuation and how do the priests
do this he says there's from the very
first something unhealthy in such
priestly aristocracies and in the habits
ruling them which turned them away from
action and alternate between brooding
and emotional explosions habits which
seem to have as they're almost
invariable consequence that almost
intestinal intestinal morbidity and
nourished neurasthenia sorry which has
afflicted priests at all times but as to
that which they themselves devised as a
remedy for this morbidity most one not
assert that has ultimately proved itself
a hundred times more dangerous in its
effects than the sickness it was
intended to cure the priest is in a
certain sense a person who is set apart
and they're set apart because they are
different from the noble ruling warrior
kingly
who are healthy able to impose their
will on others the priest is less able
to do that but the priest compensates by
finding something greater
or at least seeming to be greater the
priest opens up the possibility for the
first time of what we might call a
transcendent dimension and he says you
know he criticizes what he calls the
entire anti sensuous metaphysics of the
priests the priests are the ones not the
philosophers originally the priests are
the ones to start talking about a world
beyond this world a reality underlying
this reality and he says you know you've
talked about the auto hypnosis you know
there's a sort of fool themselves the
only two comprehensible society with all
of this together at the radical cure for
it nothingness or God for the priests
everything becomes more dangerous not
only cures and remedies but also
arrogance revenge acuteness prolific I
see love lust to rule of virtue disease
the priestly class adds a deeper
dimension to human existence it really
only becomes truly human with the advent
to that because it only becomes
historical in any meaningful sense I
think for from each other with with this
transformation so he says it's only fair
to add that it was on the soil this
essentially dangerous form of human
existence the priestly form that man
first became an interesting animal but
only here to the human soul and a higher
sense acquired depth and become evil and
these are two basic respects in which
man has hitherto been superior to other
beasts having depth and having the
possibility of evil so let's skip ahead
a little bit now he's gonna start
talking about reason to MA and
he's actually going to carry out a shift
that's a little bit ambiguous here in
this part and we want to try to keep
things as distinct as possible he starts
talking about the priestly motive al
uation and how it's different from the
nightly aristocratic one and how it can
develop into its opposite especially
when these the priests and the warrior
and jealous opposition to each other
he says the priests are the most evil
enemies why because they're the most
impotent that's kind of paradoxical so
let's say that one more time the priests
are the most evil enemies but why
because they are the most impotence it's
because of their impotent he's impotence
he says their inability to actually like
take on the warrior class and push them
down and fight them on their own terms
and also inability to get the warrior
class to recognize you know that the
priest actually you know maybe know more
or can do more in certain respects he
says it's because of their impotence
that in them hatred grows to monstrous
and uncanny proportions so the most
spiritual and poisonous kind of hatred
that's a really important point when you
have depth that depth can be filled by
love that depth can be filled by
admiration or that depth can be filled
by hatred and the priest can hate to a
degree to an extent that's really
impossible for the warrior because the
warrior doesn't have that depth of soul
even though they are you know among the
great class or things like that and he
says human history would be altogether
too stupid a thing without the spirit
that the impotent have introduced into
it so what is this the spirit he talks
about spiritual revenge and now we're
going to see the common or what he also
calls the slave introduced a new set of
valuations into morality now he's
talking very much about about Jews in
this and you want to be very careful in
understanding this
check out associated with anti-semitism
and sort of a a particularly virulent
racist German centered anti-semitism
that ultimately led to the the Holocaust
and the death camps and world war two in
general you know the whole nationalist
socialist movement it's a little bit
unfair to push nietzsche automatically
into that if you actually read this
carefully
in part because he's gonna see the
culmination of judaism actually in
christianity first off so christianity
is gonna absorb this this this
development that's taking place in
judaism and he's also going by other
people's conceptions in ancient times of
what was happening in in judaism so he
talks about a priestly people and the
reason why is time with the Jews in
particulars they sort of embody the both
priestly preoccupation and this sort of
emphasis on the the slave choice says
this alone was appropriate to priestly
people the people embodying the most
deeply repressed priestly vengeance
vengeance vengeance it was the Jews who
was inspiring consistency so he's saying
they did something that was unparalleled
in history they dared to invert the
aristocratic value equation good equals
noble equals powerful equals beauty
equals happy equals loved of God and to
hang on to this inversion with their
teeth saying the wretched alone are the
good the poor impotent lowly alone are
the good the suffering deprived sick
ugly alone or pious alone or blessed by
God blessedness is for them alone and
you the powerful and Noble are on the
contrary the evil the cruel the lustful
the insatiable the goblets to all
eternity and you shall be in all
eternity the unblessed accursed it and
the damned they says one knows who
inherited this Jewish revaluation what
does he mean there he means Christ
Christ is action
sort of embodying this valuation and
it's very interesting to think about
this if you read the Old Testament
particularly if you read you know things
like the book of Judges or some of the
books of the prophets are you really
going to get the sense of what nietzsche
is talking about here that in every
single case it's always the powerless
the weak who are good who are beloved by
God and the powerful are always bad
wicked you know the rich are always
terrible no you're not actually going to
get that conception also even if you
read the Psalms you know yes the the
pious faithful good acting you know
reliable person who is lowly is beloved
by God but so is the prince in the New
Testament if you read it a certain way
there's this complete revaluation if you
push it in the direction of you should
always be you know totally meek humble
absorb any insults that are thrown your
way pray for your enemies then you would
get to something like what Nietzsche's
is talking about and in this revaluation
with the common or slave morality it
becomes no longer a matter of good on
top of evil it becomes good or good on
top of bad it becomes the noble person
is the evil person and then the commoner
is defined as good by not being noble by
being their opposite by being not evil
so whereas with the noble valuation the
good person asserts their goodness and
then defines the others as bad and
Contra distinction to them it's the evil
that's defined first and then the good
only follows from that
a sort of shadow of it in the
revaluation that's taking place in what
nature called slave morality so he says
how did this happen he says once should
that imagine it grew up is the denial of
that thirst for revenge no other reverse
is true love like the love that you see
in the New Testament grew out of it as
its crown as its triumphant crown
spreading itself farther and farther
into the purest brightness and sunlight
driven as it were into the domain of
light and the heights and pursuit of the
goals of that hatred what are the goals
of that hatred well to dominate in every
single case each one of these things is
an expression of somebody's will
somebody's will to rule somebody's will
to dominate the weak can only rule can
only dominate by subjugating the strong
and the only way that they can subjugate
the strong is by trans valuing the
valuation that the strong have and sort
of catching them in a net a net of
morality a net of making them out to be
no longer the good but instead the evil
and what Nietzsche saying is that in the
New Testament and all these these sort
of you know works that are coming out of
this it's not really love that is
driving this so he's attacking a
Christian idea and it's very good that
God is love that Christianity is
fundamentally about love and saying no
what really fundamentally Orient's it is
actually hatred revenge and the lust to
dominate pretty interesting to think
about is in many respects Nietzsche is
kind of like a shadow augustine you know
a
inversion of Augustine and and his you
know recognition that yes there is this
lust to dominate in all of us and we
have to somehow bring it under control
otherwise love can
actually come through and we always have
to be suspicious of it so now he says
why are you talking about nobler ideals
let's stick to the fact the people of
one or the slaves or the mob or the herd
or whatever you like to call them and
this has happened through the Jews very
well and that keeps no / no people ever
had a more world historical mission the
Masters have been disposed and again you
can see that Nietzsche if you want to
accuse him of anti-semitism
it's an anti-semitism that is not really
like rooted in his in his heart and his
thought it's rather more or less saying
well I mean the Jews happen to many of
the people that this took place through
but this kind of development is taking
place and it happened it just happened
you know more with them but it happens
in any any culture where they where the
common start to become the ones who
dominate the masters have been disposed
of the morality of the common man is one
and he says the redemption of the human
race from the masters is going forward
everything is being visibly judaized but
then he says Christianized mob eyes and
they says what are the words matter so
it's not a racial thing that he is
thinking about here it's a dynamic of
development it's essentially a political
and cultural thing that he's focusing on
and he has something really interesting
he says does the church today still have
any necessary role to play does it still
have the right to exist or could one do
without it and he says is very
interesting it seems to hinder rather
than hasten this process so organized
religion which people think of
Nietzsche's being you know the great at
one of the greatest enemies of he
actually seems to think at least here
that organized religion tends to hold
back this process why because at least
with organized religion you can have
some of this stuff going on rather than
just a slave morality now we get to a
crucial point here in section 10 the
slave morass the slave revolt and
morality begins and
here he introduces this concept of
resentiment so now I need to do a bit
more erasure again because now we have a
key idea to think through and what does
result of us you can you can you know
transpose it in English and say
resentment but it's not just resentment
there's a whole dynamic that's taking
place so result them all first of all
it's any product of two things a desire
for revenge and impotence to carry it
out so it's when people desire to hurt
to retaliate but they're unable to do so
when they've been pushed down and they
can't push back up that they start to
undergo resultant and he says the result
amounts of nature's that are denied the
true reaction was the true reaction of
deeds and compensate themselves with
imaginary revenge so that's another key
things there's compensation with
imaginary
yeah and it doesn't always have to be an
imaginary just in the sense of like you
know in your head it can be taking
revenge in other ways later on putting
somebody in jail tearing them down
destroying their reputation those could
all be or writing a book about them and
saying these people are such you know
terrible people nowadays it could take
place through videotaping them I suppose
now like it says slave morality is not
an affirmation of itself how does it
develop its from the nut from the outset
it says no to what is outside to what is
different what is not itself and there's
no is its creative deed so resentiment
is a great big know so things it's not
affirmative it's only the firming
through denying it's only defining
itself by taking the other and making
the other evil and then making itself
good in response so like he says in
order to exist slave morality always
first needs a hostile external world its
action is fundamentally reaction now he
talks more about the the noble thing I'm
going to skip over this and get back to
rosante lumps so he says well the noble
man lives in trust and openness with
himself the man arose on tomate is
neither upright
nor naive nor honest and straightforward
with himself his soul squints his spirit
loves hiding places secret paths and
back doors everything covert entices him
as his world his security his
refreshment he understands how to keep
silent how not to forget how to wait how
to be provisionally self-deprecating and
humble a race of such men of
ressentiment is bound to become
eventually cleverer than any noble race
it will also honor cleverness to a far
greater degree so he says
the noble person by contrast can't take
one's enemies accidents or one's
misdeeds seriously for very long that's
a sign of strong full nature's in whom
there's an excess of the power to form
to mold to recuperate and to forget such
a man shakes off with a single shrug
many vermin that eat deep into others
here alone nature says is genuine love
of one's enemies love of one's enemies
being means not really taking notice of
what they do to you because you're so
strong that they can't really hurt you
anyway
now the person of Rozonda mom doesn't do
that he says that the the person of
result in love brings in the enemy in a
very different way for the first time
and he says I'm going to go on with this
yeah here we go
I'll come back to normal in a moment
where is this left us where is this
Broadus - he calls it the Dominion and
leveling of European man of modern
culture so what is what does he actually
taking place with that lets actually
let's go back and talk about the the
noble he says the noble if this is easy
to understand if you look at things like
Homer or other other Greek write
writings and epics or if you look at
other cultures epics as well he says the
same men worst held so sternly in check
among their their equals by custom
respect usage gratitude and even more by
mutual suspicion and jealousy and who on
the other hand their relations with each
other show themselves so resourceful and
consideration self-control delicacy
loyalty pride and friendship that's what
they display to others on their same
rank to the ones who are different than
them they are just like you know
devastators there are their conquerors
they come in they're barbarians but they
have culture at least at their own
stratum what does culture mean for us
what does culture mean for Western
culture Western democracy Western
development all these sorts of things
Nietzsche says supposing that that what
at any rate is believed to be the truth
really is true the meaning of all
culture is the reduction of the beast of
prey man to attainment civilized animal
a domestic animal then one would
undoubtedly have to regard all those
instincts of reaction and rose on
two-month cruise through whose aid the
noble races and their ideals were fine
they can found it and overthrown as the
instruments of culture as development as
going higher and higher and higher when
really things have been brought lower
and lower and lower so he says how would
we know if that's the case have things
really been getting better and better
and better
as we've democratized as we've found
everybody who's marginalized and brought
them into the limelight made space for
them and not allowed them to be bullied
or exploited or pick whatever you like
by the strong what has happened but you
said something really interesting here
and now we get to another issue that's
very closely tied with resultant law and
that is what we call Neil ISM Nietzsche
says what does culture mean to us now
what does culture actually provided us
what is it actually given to us he says
one may be quite justified in continuing
to fear the blonde Beast at the core of
all noble races and then being in on
one's guard against it but who would not
a hundred times sooner fear where one
can also admire than not fear but be
permanently condemned to the repellent
site of the ill constituted dwarfed
atrophied and poisoned and is that not
our fate he's asking this about Western
culture in general is that not our fate
that we've been condemned to you know no
longer have nobility present is
something that we can look up to what
today constitutes our anticipated
antipathy to man for we suffer he says
from man beyond doubt not fear for
rather that we no longer have anything
left to fear in man that the maggot man
is swarming in the foreground that the
tame man the hopelessly mediocre an
insipid man has already learned to feel
himself as the goal in the zenith as the
meaning of history as higher man that he
has indeed a certain right to feel thus
insofar as he feels himself elevated
above the surface of ill constituted
sickly weary and exhausted people of
which Europe is beginning to distinct
today as something at least relatively
well constituted and he's still capable
of living at least affirming life you
can see how much self-loathing is
involved in this this culture
you know and if we were going to
transpose this into today you know is
our own culture Nielsen ratings and
American Idol and pick whatever other
you know sort of leveling things you
like where we make everything about what
a majority of people think and we turn
people essentially just into consumers
and voters does that actually produce
much of great value culturally Nietzsche
would ask us and he goes on and he says
this is how things are the diminution
and leveling of European man constitutes
our greatest danger our greatest danger
he says for the sight of him makes us
weary we can see nothing today that
wants to grow greater we suspect that
things will continue to go down down to
become thinner more good-natured more
prudent more comfortable more mediocre
more indifferent here's where he says
something interesting more Chinese more
Christian because talking together this
notion of sort of like an imperial China
where everybody knows their place and
nobody's disturbs anything well then
he's bringing up you know sort of
cultural Christianity along with this he
says here precisely is what has become a
fatality for Europe together with the
fear of man we've also lost our love for
him Nietzsche thinks that genuine love
for man is not possible in results
amount that you know it may posture that
way amazed the words of love to harness
people in to put them down to deprive
the powerful of their power but we but
it doesn't really love we have lost our
love of him or reverence for him our
hopes for him even the will to him we've
lost our capacity to choose something
higher he says the sight of man no makes
us weary what is nihilism today if not
that we are weary of man so he's giving
you a definition of nihilism that is not
exactly the same as what he talks about
in other works but it's it's weariness
of the human condition as we know it in
our culture because of these
transformations that have taken place
that we
yeah I'm gonna skip ahead a little bit
he's got some great stuff discussing
resulta month but I want to skip ahead
to the section 16 where he's drawing a
conclusion he says let us conclude the
two opposing values and what he means my
values are systems of values good and
bad which is what the noble person
evaluates in terms of good and evil
which is what the base person the slave
the common person evaluates in terms of
these two values have been engaged in a
fearful struggle on earth for thousands
of years and though the latter value has
certainly been on top what does it mean
the latter value good and evil with evil
being the noble and good being the
person who's you know not rocking the
boat the mediocre that's been on top for
a long time there are still places where
the struggle is yet undecided now here
he's gonna say something very important
particularly for anybody who would be
attracted to Nietzsche's thought and
want to try to think it out he says one
might say it is even risen it has risen
to even higher and thus become more and
more profound and spiritual so that
today there's perhaps no more decisive
mark of a higher nature a more spiritual
nature than that of being divided in
this sense and a genuine battleground of
these opposed values what that means is
that nature is saying that one of the
marks of spiritual profundity in a
person is that both of these two
valuations are still fighting within
that person he's not saying that the you
know blond beast the the Superman who
you know totally you know poses their
will on everybody else and creates new
values and all that sort of stuff he's
not saying that is the deepest thing
he's saying that really we ought to feel
this tension this conflict not just
outside of us in the culture where we
say oh I'm going to go this way or I'm
going to go this way but going right
down the middle of our very
that we can't extricate ourselves so
easily from this situation we ought to
feel torn between these two different
valuations so he says the symbol of this
struggle and now he's going to give us a
little bit of history
his Rome against Judea Judea against
Rome there is hitherto been no greater
event than this struggle this question
this deadly contradiction Rome felt the
Jew to be something like anti nature
itself the Jews stood convicted of
hatred for the whole human race
according to the Romans how on the other
hand of the Jews feel about Rome a
thousand science tells us but it suffice
us to recall the apocalypse of John the
last book of the vine the Bible also
called the Book of Revelations if you
actually read through that book it is
not a particularly loving book compared
to other parts of the New Testament it's
more like and then those bastards are
going to get what's coming to them it's
much more like other apocalyptic books
and if you wanted to pick a book that
might exhibit results in law that might
actually be the book for you
I don't think you're gonna find that
much result amant say in Matthew
compared or you know on certain letters
compared to what the revelations and he
says for the Romans were the strong and
Noble and nobody stronger and nobler has
ever existed on earth or ever been
dreamed of that's an interesting thing
for me to say cuz you know we could have
talked about the Mongols could have
talked about other groups but he took
the Romans for that every remnant of
them every inscription gives delight if
one only Divine's what it was that that
was there at work the Jews on the
contrary were the priestly nation of
ressentiment par excellence in which
there dwelt an unequaled popular moral
genius he says what only has to compare
similarly gifted nations like the
Chinese or the Germans with the Jews to
see which of them this is a really
interesting thing which of them is of
the first rank in which of them is a
fifth rank what does Nietzsche's saying
here the Jews when it comes to like
moral determinations first rank the
Germans fifth rank which of them one for
the present Rome or Judea there can be
no doubt considered a whom one vows down
in Rome itself today as if they are the
epitome of
the highest values and not only in Rome
but over half the earth everywhere that
man has become tamer desires to become
tame three Jews and one Jew s Jesus of
Nazareth the fisherman Peter the rug
weaver Paul and the mother of the
aforementioned Jesus named Mary
Rome has been defeated beyond a doubt he
says so he's tracing out a history yeah
a genealogy right a moral valuation then
he says okay so for a long time Rome was
subjected in the Renaissance he says
things started to come back to life and
why did they die out the Reformation he
says Judea immediately triumphed again
thanks to that thoroughly plebeian
result about movement called the
Reformation and to that which was bound
to arise from it restoration of the
church with the French Revolution now
the French Revolution was anti-clerical
right anti religious shouldn't that have
been maybe a restoration of the noble
idea no because it was democratic with
the French revelation Judea once again
triumphed over the classical idea and
this time in an even more profound and
decisive sense the last political
noblesse in Europe that of the French
17th and 18th century collapsed under
the popular instincts of rose on Tomaso
nature saying result amount was behind
the French Revolution as well
greater rejoicing more uproarious
enthusiasm had never been heard on earth
and then he says Napoleon of course
appeared the most isolated and late
bored man there's ever been and in him
the problem of the noble ideal is such
made flesh one may well wonder what kind
of problem it is Napoleon the synthesis
of the inhuman and superhuman Napoleon
sort of imposing his will and values
kind of you know the way the the noble
did before but doing so in the service
of an empire and a bureaucracy and a
democratized regime which is that of the
rebel
in some more twists and turns that we
see going on in this study of the
genealogy of morals Nietzsche is going
to examine the history of these
developments he's been flush out a
little bit better this notion of the the
priestly caste he's going to develop
this notion of resentiment slave
morality in greater detail so that's
what we're going to be looking at in the
next couple chapters